I was 19 and I was in the hotel room
with a bunch of actors and [ __ ] and
there was somebody on a like it was like
a show like Jerry Springer and they were
dressed so funky and I was like damn
Louie that that's crazy how they're
dressed and some guy goes one of the
actors who's actually kind of famous
right now and I'm not gonna blow up his
spot but this guy was a [ __ ] dick to
me he goes he says uh bro you ever been
in New York like and I will of course I
wanted to knock him out and I go like
this my man I live in LA you know don't
come at me with your stupid New York
[ __ ]
by the way yeah I've been in New York
I'm from New Jersey
my dad used to work in New York don't
[ __ ] come at me with that face crime
[ __ ] don't come at me when I'm like wow
that guy's crazy
and then this guy comes up to me and
he's like this you ever been in New York
face crime don't face crime me in a
[ __ ] hotel room in Vancouver British
Columbia dude you're gonna do face crime
to me in Canada talking about New York
I'm from LA dude [ __ ] ass get out of
here
it's all right actor he's good actor you
know
but I don't give a [ __ ] dude because you
did face crime and if you do face crime
you're out anyway my point is I would
have lost in 1984 I would have got
[ __ ] studded up the whole time I
would have got stood up I would have got
studded up every day cuz there's no way
I can hold my face crying I can't
thoughtcrime no way I'm thinking that
everyone's a [ __ ] idiot I mean are
you [ __ ] kidding me no way a girl
passed me a note that says she loved me
I would of my heart would have beat it
and I would've been like oh my god
studded that studded in jail for years
vaporized
anyway dude
face crimes are real thing and we got to
[ __ ] get in control of it it's it's
it's like that kind of thing is what
this that kind of thought is what this
podcast is largely against that kind of
like bro you ever been in New York that
thought is what this part that kernel of
what that guy is is what this this
podcast is against the guy who's always
trying to see more interesting than the
next guy no because you've been in New
York you're somebody bro get the [ __ ]
out of here
it's like the whole [ __ ] it's like
it's like it's like the thing it's like
the dad bod thing it's like the pizza
thing oh I'm so interesting how much I
like pizza and I'm so skinny go [ __ ]
yourself dude you're not interesting get
a personality don't eat pizza get a
purse
don't buy a pizza get a personality get
a personality with some [ __ ] toppings
on it dude get a meatlovers personality
okay get a Papa John's personality
because you're not [ __ ] interesting
just because you ordered a pizza and
pose near it now that's the kind of [ __ ]
that we're talking about my babies this
dad bought [ __ ] [ __ ] take a take a
[ __ ] lunch take a [ __ ] hike bring
your lunch dude dad bought you're not
interesting because you say I prefer a
dad bout over a six-pack
I get the sentiment I get what you're
saying you don't like guys that take
themselves too seriously and you don't
like a guy who's too into himself but
that doesn't mean you want a fat guy
face crime that doesn't mean that and if
you say that you're not interesting
because you think you are and the least
interesting people are the people who
think they're interesting oh dude me I'm
quirky I like a guy with love handles no
you don't take any guy you take your
boyfriend you'd like it if you [ __ ]
trimmed up a little bit period you don't
know but I like his dad but know what
you're saying is you like his
personality we get that but all
so hey bud tighten it up go ahead make
excuses make excuses for everybody
that's fine we're all gonna be [ __ ]
fat pieces of [ __ ] that's it
I can tell well beyond your [ __ ] man
and and you should be able to to that's
the sentiment that this podcast is all
against and that's why this is a cult
and we are fighting against that [ __ ]
[ __ ] dadbod there are people who
literally think no I actually really do
prefer a dad bod and say no you don't
dude no you don't and people are like oh
well ok if Chris D'Elia says ok straight
white male some people look straight
white male says dad bods are out ok fine
dude go ahead go ahead
alright fine but that's not the truth
lie to yourself also and then the
article where they were like hey dad
bods are in it's like it showed Leonardo
DiCaprio and [ __ ] Chris Pratt from
seven years ago but you mean guys with
money and fame are in show a real dad
bad guy so some guy you saw at the
[ __ ] shop right earlier getting a
bunch of ham and some rolls show that
guy
oh you don't cuz who is he a fat guy a
fact
um and it's fine to be fat and it's fine
to love who you are you should I'm
comfortable in my own body great cool be
comfortable be fat comfortable but don't
act like you're more attracted to a dad
bod than you are with a guy who's got a
[ __ ] you know who's trimming it up
I'm not talking about the guy who's
[ __ ] obnoxiously large and muscle
why's that guy's annoying his [ __ ] - um
yeah man we get it be comfortable with
your body sure for sure but also it's
better to be trim it's better to be
healthy it's better to be moving it's
better be active dude you know